this video is brought to you by brilliant
get a free trial with brilliant and take
advantage of its hands-on stem learning
lessons more on them in a little bit
today's story begins with a website
heavensgate.com its homepage screams
old school internet with its colorful
text in times new roman font set against a
starry background the relic of the early
days of the web which may induce laughter in
new generations and even some nostalgia among
boomers if you skim through the contents of
the website you may consider it the rambling yet
harmless front for some new age group but if you
look closer you'll notice the alarming red alert
blinking at the top runs the striking sentences
below the organization's logo our 22 years
of classroom here on planet earth is finally
coming to conclusion or we are happily prepared
to leave this world again it may appear like
harmless spiritualist content but this website
is one of the most chilling suicide notes
you'll ever read the organization heaven's gate
described either as a new religious movement or
a cult counted only about 40 members as of
march 1997. on the 26th of that month local
police broke into their communal residence rancho
santa fe san diego they found 39 bodies 21 women
and 18 men who had willingly come to end their
journey on planet earth 21 women and 18 men had
committed suicide to follow the teachings
of their leader marshall hirth applewhite
martial earth applewhite was born on may 17
1931 in spur texas one of four siblings born
in a loving family his father marshall senior was
a presbyterian minister who moved his family every
few years founding a number of churches around
south texas during this nomadic existence hearth
developed a passion for music and especially for
singing at the same time he yearned to follow in
his father's footsteps after graduating from high
school in 1948 hearth enrolled in austin college
in sherman texas with the intention of becoming
a minister himself it's common for future cult
leaders to display signs of malignant narcissism
from their early years but this was not the case
with hearth applewhite his former roommate stated
that hearth was smart popular extroverted magnetic
without being pushy he also commented that
applewhite did not show any fanatically religious
tendencies dedicating equal amounts of time
and energy to theology pre-christian philosophy
and choral music after graduating from austin
applewhite enrolled at the union theological
seminary of virginia in richmond after three
years of further studies he would be ordained
a presbyterian minister but after his first
seminar herff dropped out of school to pursue a
career in music even if still tied to a religious
environment he moved to gastonia north carolina
to take a post as a director of music at the
local first presbyterian church by this time
applewhite had married anne pearce and both of
them left only fond memories amongst the gastonia
congregation colleagues in the music department
remembered her as a strong but personable leader
so another confirmation of applewhite's undeniable
charisma and leadership skills unfortunately only
two years later the applewhites had to forcibly
leave gastonia when herf was drafted into the
army they relocated first to salzburg austria and
then to white sands new mexico where he served as
an instructor for the signal corps this is the
first divergence point in marshall applewhite's
biographical accounts according to some sources
he served well and received an honorable discharge
in 1956 but according to other accounts he was
dishonorably discharged on charges of alleged
homosexual activity with a recruit during
the 1960s the applewhites moved around the
state changing a number of jobs frequently
connected to music according to his own cv
marshall applewhite worked as a cantorial soloist
in a houston temple as a singer and conductor in
cultural and commercial music in new york before
perfecting his singing studies in germany in 1964
marshall's singing career was in full swing
he was signed up by the houston grand opera
with which he sang ten major roles in a production
of faust he even performed alongside tenor placido
domingo in 1966 he took on a second job as the
head of music at houston's university of st
thomas a catholic institution despite his
professional commitments marshall maintained a
good work-life balance and was a loving father to
his kids striving to make their childhood as warm
and magical as possible according to marshall's
sister he once brought home a tree propped it up
in his living room and decked it in white paint
and turquoise decorations just for the sake of it
so by the age of 35 marshall hearth applewhite was
a loving husband caring father respected teacher
and appreciated opera singer all fired and dandy
all instruments in tune and performing on the beat
but soon some elements out of scale would enter
the symphony and cause dissonance in the harmony
the turning point in the life of marshall hirth
applewhite was his first encounter with bonnie lou
trusdale nettles sometime in 1972. a nurse by
trade she had a strong interest in occultism in
1966 she had joined the houston lodge of the
theosophical society and later enrolled into
a group dedicated to channeling non-corporeal
entities she frequently claimed being in touch
with one of these such entities a disembodied
19th century monk named brother francis and
apparently brother francis guided and influenced
her decisions on a regular basis so how did the
two meet well also here we have not one but two
divergence points which makes their love story all
the more unconventional according to some sources
close to heaven's gate marshall first met bonnie
while tutoring her daughter as a music teacher
both applewhite and nettles were heading towards
the end of their respective marriages and so
they grew very close their friendship eventually
developed into a romantic relationship even if one
of a very peculiar kind and we'll get into that in
a bit another version of the fateful encounter was
told by marshall's sister louise winand according
to her in 1972 marsha was hospitalized in houston
with a heart blockage the condition was so
serious that he had a near-death experience upon
recovery marshall befriended one of the nurses
who told him that he had a purpose that god kept
him alive that nurse was bonnie nettles the third
and final version of the event may be the one
closest to the truth and relates to what later
emerged about marshall's troubled sexuality
in this reality continuum we have to go back
to 1970. but this time applewhite was fired from
the university of st thomas administrators had
learned that marshall was in a relationship with a
male student and so they dismissed him for health
problems of an emotional nature the firing led to
deep feelings of shame then depression apparently
applewhite started hearing voices around him this
deterioration in mental health led him to check
into a psychiatric hospital in 1971 where he asked
to be cured of his homosexuality which by the way
was considered a mental disorder by the american
psychiatric association until 1974. it was while
in psychiatric care that marshall first met bonnie
when they first bonded she started calling him bo
and he referred to her as peep peep introduced bo
to occultism acting as a sort of gateway figure
into anything that belonged to the supernatural
sphere disembodied souls ufos different planes
of existence etc yet all of peep's teachings were
grounded in christianity in fact in 1971 the two
formed a partnership called the christian arts
center where they offered classes in religion
art and music only later was the center re-branded
as the no place and occult teachings became more
prominent marshall's sister louise remembers
how this partnership was not exactly formed on
a reciprocal basis sure peep always
considered the two of them co-leaders of
the no place but beau introduced his partner as
the senior leader acknowledging her more advanced
spiritual knowledge after all peep was the teacher
beau was the learner peep was the recruiter bo the
proselyte and a very enthusiastic one of that
at the time bo applewhite was still working in
a theater group in houston one of his colleagues
was patsy swayze mother of actor patrick swayze
she recalled how her usually level-headed co-star
had suddenly started to act strangely talking
about ufos and preaching this strange religion
that's right bo and peep had created their own new
religious movement or cult depending on the point
of view in 1974 bo and peep changed their names to
dough and tea they began an evangelical journey to
preach their new gospel by this time the two would
become an item of course but their relationship
even if romantic was always platonic it appears
that after his stint in psychiatric care doe had
completely renounced sexuality and this suited tea
well to a t both admitted not having the slightest
physical attraction to each other and even later
incorporated abstention from sex as one of their
cult's tenants at some points after the start
of their liaison doe even had himself castrated
it sounds like thou shall not fornicate was one
of their commandments but the same did not apply
to thou shall not steal in fact while touring
texas doe and tea were arrested in harlingen
for credit card fraud the charges were dropped
but police found that applewhite was also wanted
for car theft he had rented a vehicle in st louis
and never returned it so t got away scot-free
while doe spent six months in prison soon after
his release doe and tea cut off ties with their
respective families marshall visited his sister
louise in dallas one last time louise had realized
that her brother had become a different person in
the span of just a couple of years and remarked
what's the matter with you that's not the real you
he replied you just don't know the real me now
we'll get back to today's video in just a moment
but first here's a quick word from today's video
sponsor brilliant there's no better way to learn
the might working through problems yourself and
brilliant provides you exactly that opportunity
brilliant's a new learning platform that lets
you tackle new maths science and computer science
concepts in fun hands-on ways for example if you
ever wanted to learn how computer programming
works but were put off or intimidated by opaque
coding language well brilliant can help you learn
how to program without having to dig deep through
the weeds of coding syntax that's thanks to fun
interactive challenges brilliant users can shift
around blocks of pseudo code then get immediate
feedback on their results on brilliant it's not
about memorizing or regurgitating facts for a test
you could just pick a course you're interested in
and get started feeling stuck afraid you made a
mistake that's never an issue here you can read
the explanation to find out more and learn at
your own pace as the holiday season arrives
remember brilliant makes an amazing gift for
any of the ambitious learners in your life whether
it's an inquisitive niece an all-knowing parent
or the neighbor who already seems to have
everything i know you're curious loved ones
from every age group will be excited to jump
into brilliant interactive learning approach
right now the first 200 viewers who head to
the link in the description below will get
20 percent off brilliant's annual premium
subscription for yourself or someone else
definitely a good time to check out brilliant
and now let's get back to today's video
doe and t resumed their odyssey of enlightenment
t was pretty much the sage behind the scenes
while dough exploited his natural charisma
to preach and present their religious views
so it's now time to describe what exactly
were the beliefs of the religious movement
or cult which became known as heaven's gate
and we must confess that it's not an easy task
heaven's gate always rejected the label of ufo
cult but it's easy to see how they got that stamp
one central belief is that humans coexist with two
celestial races inhabiting space one of them are
those inhabiting terla or the evolutionary level
above human members of tele can visit earth by
inhabiting a human body this is the case for
example with the two witnesses described in
the book of revelation in revelation chapter
11 verses 1-14 the story is told of how two
witnesses spread a message of judgment but were
martyred they were then resurrected and taken to
heaven in a cloud doe and he interpreted this
cloud to be a spaceship furthermore they were
convinced that they were the two witnesses
mentioned in the gospel in later stages doe
would even claim that jesus christ was a being
from turla who had accepted death so that he
could return to a higher level of existence on a
spacecraft that being then returned to earth after
2000 years inhabiting the body of well you guessed
it marshall applewhite the other celestial races
were so-called luciferians or fallen angels
followers of satan they were expelled from
tala and have plunged into earth inhabiting
human bodies these luciferian human hybrids
are responsible for ruining the planet and any
opposition to the truth professed by heaven's gate
comes from them of course the other central tenet
is that every human body is merely a shell for an
asexual soul this soul can be liberated from its
earthly bounds and find salvation in outer space
thus reaching teller in his initial teachings doe
preached that the soul could reach the next level
only while the body was still intact but we'll
see a bit later how he contradicted himself
in 1975 darwin t made it into the news after a
convention in waldport oregon they convinced a
group of 20 people to follow them to eastern
colorado where a ufo was due to land in
the desert the prostatites firmly believed
that the spaceship would take them on board
and fly them to the next level i hope we're
not surprising anybody by saying that this
momentous voyage of discovery turns into
a rather awkward camping trip doe and he
surprisingly maintained most of their following
after this disappointment and the group relocated
first to denver then to fort worth in their new
base doentee maintained a low profile as they
had started to attract much unwanted media
scrutiny instead they sent some of their followers
to travel the nation as missionaries recruiting
up to 200 members the two spiritual leaders then
subjected their followers to a series of practices
routines and habits which tested their commitment
and their beliefs members of heaven's gate
had to pledge to a strict rule of uniformity
their hair was shorn their clothes replaced with
baggy androgynous outfits which annulled their
individuality and gender identities their diets
were strictly controlled sometimes consisting of
entirely pureed or even liquid foods drinking
smoking drugs all was strictly forbidden but
the strictest set of restrictions concerned sex
dough and tea demanded from their acolytes to lead
entirely celibate lives no sex among each other
let alone outsiders sexual abstinence was such an
integral part of their lifestyle that following
doe's example many male members decided to let
go of well they're members yes we're talking
about elective castration unsurprisingly such
a strict lifestyle alienated many followers
but that did not worry dough too much as
long as he had tea by his side little did he know
that she too would soon leave him behind in the
early 1980s bonnie nettles was diagnosed with late
stage cancer in 1983 the disease spread so badly
that she had to have one eye removed but the tumor
continued to progress and she developed metastases
in her liver there wasn't much that could be done
and she died in june of 1985. applewhite until now
had followed bonnie's guidance now he was on his
own and he had to improvise he had been teaching
that only the living would have been taken aboard
a spaceship and onto the higher level how could
he justify bonnie's death to his most loyal
worshippers he simply modified heaven's gate
theology the human soul was an immortal essence
which could detach itself from the mortal body
and travel to the next level where it would
be reincarnated into another corporeal vessel
t had been the first to go to prepare a place for
the rest of them by the late 1980s applewhite had
resumed his recruiting efforts adding a new
apocalyptic element to his credo applewhite's
take on the end of days was later documented
in a series of speeches which he circulated on
videotape and public access tv announcements in
these talks doe warned that our planet was about
to be recycled refurbished started over at the end
of the age the planet is wiped clean refurbished
rejuvenated the mess that the humans have made
of it during this civilization is cleaned up and
you prophesied that the only ones who survive
the recycling are the ones who want to leave
by 1996 marshall applewhite could count on about
40 followers they lived communally pooling their
resources and exploring innovative income
streams the group was rather tech savvy and
was probably the first cult-like organization to
make extensive use of the internet to communicate
their activities they even set up a digital
marketing agency called hiresource specializing
in web design and search engine optimization
their success with clients such as the san
diego polo club granted them enough income to
rent a large house in rancho santa fe san diego
it was in the first weeks of 1997 that applewood
first claimed to be the second coming of jesus he
explained to his followers that 2000 years prior
he had accepted his death so that he could travel
back to tala and then he asked the group what
if we had to exit our vehicles by our own choice
this is the first time he mentioned the idea of
mass suicide only one member objected packed his
bags and left the cult so what could have
motivated dough's decision probably it was
the appearance of the comet hail bob heaven's gate
saw this as a sign a portent applewhite spread the
idea that another celestial object a spacecraft
was following in its wake this was the signal
that the members were ready to leave their bodies
and board the spacecraft where tea was waiting for
a crew of higher beings then what could have
motivated 38 of dough's followers to yield
to his decision unlike jim jones and the people's
temple the cult was under neither external threat
nor internal violent cohesion early explanations
from popular media have attributed the act to
applewhite brainwashing his followers but academic
writers studying new religious movements such as
professor george cassadies have long dismissed the
concept of brainwashing referring to charismatic
leadership instead according to this principle
charisma is something negotiated between leaders
and followers those who chose to follow the leader
choose to do so on their own volition because
they agree with his or her teachings as time
moves on the demands of the leader may be met
with approval or disapproval by some members
that is what happened with heaven's gate life
of abstinence from sex and human interaction is
bound to have a high rate of attrition there is a
natural selection so that only those who really
want to stay do so and those who stay develop
increasing familiarity and trust with the leader
thus becoming more and more compliant long-term
members also find it more difficult to disengage
and return to a previous lifestyle of which they
have only distant memories this difficulty allows
the leader to make heightened demands and claims
upon the followers the last of these demands was
sadly an unusual type of mass suicide unusual
because rather than presenting death as the lesser
of two evils it offered it as a necessary passage
for a higher reward in heaven on march 21 1997
the members of heaven gate ate a last supper
at a local restaurant turkey pot pie cheesecake
with blueberries and iced tea they then prepared
for their space travel they dressed in long
sleeve shirts black sweatpants and nike decades
a patch on their tops read heaven's gateway team
the suicide ritual was performed in shifts spread
over three days first they drank citrus juices
to cleanse their bodies of impurities then they
downed a lethal dose of phenobarbitals some
mixed with applesauce some with vodka then they
fastened plastic bags over their head to induce
asphyxiation one by one all 39 awaited death and
an ascent to a spaceship that had sailed only
through the cosmos of applewhite's darkened mind
the death toll was not complete though even after
jesus reincarnate marshall doe applewhite was no
longer among them two further members felt
compelled to fill his wishes they attempted
to copycat suicide in a hotel room and one of them
died immediately the survivor committed his next
attempt in february 1998 killing himself in the
arizona desert this marked the end of heaven's
gate one of the most puzzling and shocking cults
of the later years of the 20th century or was it
really the end apparently two individuals who
identified themselves as mark and sarah king
aka the tala foundation have been keeping alive
the message of dough on social media and have
even provided copies of applewhite's videotapes
on request in reddit interviews they claimed that
dohan the 38 who departed had left them behind on
purpose to quote the information must be available
to mankind in preparation for their return so i
hope you found this video interesting if you did
please do hit that thumbs up button below don't
forget to subscribe and thank you for watching